- Oh, my gosh. I'm so excited to meet you!
- [Cristo] Oh, thank you very much.
- I love the show!
I know I said that in the card I gave you,
but I'm still obsessed with the show.
I scream "football is life," all the time.
Meet JoJo though. Y'all get to meet now.
- Nice to meet you.
- So you really are a
football player, right?
- Yeah. Well, I mean, I
used to play professionally,
since I was a kid.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah, my grandma,
when I started to walk,
my grandma taught me how to
play in the garage of my house.
I was always carrying a ball with me.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah, football was
part of me since a kid,
then playing professionally when I was 15.
And then later in life, I
stopped when I decided to study.
And my parents told me to
study and intelligently,
because I had some injuries,
but then yeah, football
has been part of my life.
- Oh, my God. It's so fitting.
So this is actually my
favorite thing about you,
that I learned, I didn't know,
you know like so many languages.
- Yes.
- I think that's amazing! What
all languages do you know?
- I speak English of course, I think.
French, German, and a bit of Italian,
and Spanish is my mother tongue.
- Oh, my gosh.
Okay, could you teach us
how to say "football is life" in French?
- In French.
(speaking French)
- In German.
(speaking German)
(Kelly speaking in German)
(Cristo repeating German phrase)
- Foosball, that's like the other movies.
(JoJo speaking in German)
- So how did you land
the role on "Ted Lasso,"
other than being perfect for it?
- Well, thank you.
Well, I started my master
in acting in the UK.
I saved money over there
and before going to the UK,
and then I was in Mexico
and I received the
audition for "Ted Lasso."
I did it, didn't hear anything.
They started shooting in August.
So I thought, well, nothing happened.
But then I received a random
tweet from Bill Lawrence,
a showrunner of the show,
who said just, "good audition, man."
And I was like, okay,
either he's playing with my feelings
or there's something good happening.
- Oh, my God. That'd be so mean.
- Yeah. And then I did more auditions,
and story short, I got the
role for an Icelandic man.
So when I arrived on
set I was called Gooner,
and I was like, if I'm
playing an Icelandic man,
I need more preparation.
- Wait, what?
So originally it wasn't even
the role you're in right now?
- No, no, no.
The role was for a guy from Iceland,
but they liked my audition,
from what I know now,
that they kept it
and that's why they
adapted it to who I am.
- Oh, my God. I love
it! You were so great!
That's amazing.
But are you getting recognized everywhere?
- Well, yeah, here in LA.
This is where I realized that the bit of
the craziness around the show,
which I'm grateful and stuff.
Yeah. Lots of fans.
I have a funny anecdote
that recently, well,
I was in a commercial
center, I went to the toilet,
and then I was about to wee
and I just feel someone staring at me.
And I'm like...
And then this guy, very happy,
and he just says, "are you the
smiley guy from "Ted Lasso?"
Not even my character,
and I'm like, "yeah."
And he's goes like,
"can I have a picture?"
- Can you give me a minute?
- Not right now.
- And I was like, "um, okay."
- You're like, shaking! Ha ha.
- And then we got this selfie,
and he just, "thank you,
man," and he leaves.
And I was like, "what
the hell just happened?"
- That has happened to me in a bathroom.
I have literally, I went in the bathroom,
I sat down to pee and literally,
someone just slid paper
and pen under the thing.
And I was like, "all right."
- If you've got the guts to do that!
I was like, if you're okay with it.
This is your opportunity.
I get it, seize the moment.
Has that ever happened
to you? Anything weird?
- Oh, yeah. bathrooms are just,
- [Kelly] You get trapped.
- You get trapped.
And it's the worst one like for me,
'cause it's like, teenage
girls just follow me in
and it'll be like a squad.
You know, if I go to Disneyland
there's like, squads of
teenage girls that'll go,
and they'll follow me into a bathroom.
And then you come out and you're bombarded
with seven random girls
just waiting there.
And you're like, "hello, thank you."
- Yeah. I hope, I please
hope that you just go,
"it all went well, thank
you," and just keep walking.
The show is nominated for a lot of Emmys
and you were also nominated
for an Imagen, right?
- Yeah. Oh, thank you guys. Yeah.
I'm very happy for the nominations
for the show in the Emmys.
But yeah, we got this Imagen award,
which awards, Latin talent.
And I'm just very grateful.
and especially with the
people I'm nominated with.
And I share the news with my family
and my family was more excited
with the fact that I was
nominated with Mario Lopez.
(laughing)
Because, I grew up...
Yeah. Yeah. I love that.
- [Kelly] I love Mario.
I love him, and we love him.
And I grew up watching
"Saved by the Bell,"
- [Kelly] Me too.
so my parents were like,
"oh, my God. I love this!"
- I want to be in "Zack
Attack." Yeah, that's cool.
I want to be in "Zack
Attack," very much so.
He was always cool.
He made the Speedo look very nice.